hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're going to try
to get the authorization working the
user login for our app and so I've done
some troubleshooting today and I think
I've ruled out the the email as the
issue so yesterday we were thinking that
there was maybe a port that was blocked
that was stopping emails from working
but that's not the case so I was able to
test that out and on the master branch I
don't have the login implemented but the
email is there when you submit the form
that I was going to show you but I can't
log in right now so if we could log in
there's a form all right so we can get
to it on the master branch I can submit
it successfully and I can get the email
so that works so it's not the email so
we have to look elsewhere so I did kind
of scatter i scattered console logs all
over the place throughout some of our
node files here and I didn't I didn't
come up with any definitive but I think
it may have something to do with the
database connection let me show you my
my logs here so this is what I keep
getting
let's see here we go so this this error
is is coming from [ __ ] client dot J s
that's the area that I keep getting
every time I try to log in so between
what I was able to do with all the
console logs and be able to successfully
send emails and this error message that
leads me to believe that maybe it has
something to do with how we're
interacting with with that database so I
figure that's not a bad place to start
with our troubleshooting
so let's it was not much to see here
just you know we can submit see actually
let me restart this because we're not
gonna get this will refresh
all right let me check the live chat
before we get started and then I'll
start my timer and we'll do 25 minutes
of in this case troubleshooting we may
or not may or may not be writing that
much code so you could see this is this
is what happens when you submit we just
keep getting the same error sorry it's
just everything set up hey everybody
CEO saying hey air in the live chat
sebastian is asking if the the pool
request he submitted to fix that UI
glitch that was happening with the the
drop down for to log out so i did emerge
in that pool request i as far as i know
it was working alright i didn't have
time to test it that much so it was only
really minimal changes just to CSS so i
figured there's no harm in and merging
it in but my take truth my browser stack
has been insanely slow lately so if
you're not familiar browser stack you
can run you can test your websites on
all different types of browser operating
system device combinations so it's like
you through your browser you can log in
to these other devices and test it so
for whatever reason it's just been
really weird and slow and hard to test
so i didn't test it yet just because I'm
tired of the frustration of working with
that
so anyway it's it's in the master branch
now so if anyone once has the code on
your machine and you're running an on
Mac please let me know if you see
anything weird when you click on that
that menu to
logout but I think it should be fun
okay
all right so I have some some comments
pertaining to the troubleshooting so
let's just go right into that and and
check out these comments I'm going to
start my timer after this 25 minutes is
up I'm going to take five minutes and go
through the questions in the live chat
so if you ask a question I will get to
it eventually just hang in there and and
you'll get your answer if you can't
stick around for the answer just check
out the recording of this video which
will be available here on the free code
camp YouTube channel
shortly after I finished the stream
alright so okay so Paco asks did you try
to connect your mom go on another port
okay no I haven't let's see and Harshit
is asking about a user I've already
created a user in the in the [ __ ]
database so I'm using M lab just the
free version of M lab just to set up a
testing database so I do have a user
created and that's the the user that I'm
working with for for my database so
where you have to put in your database
user and password that's that's what I
am using
okay Sebastian followed up with
initially talking about pull requests
yes the white space was gone so there's
no white space any there anymore they're
on a Mac so that that issue was cleared
up so thank you
let's see
okay so I'm trying to I'm trying to sort
out Harshit is the one that that coded
this pretty much everything having to do
with the back end was done by Harsha so
I'm trying to read these comments
helping me out here so so harsh it's
saying check your dot and file okay so
what what do I need to check the string
I have checked the string it's it's
worth double-checking okay I should
saying to use use his connection string
okay let's see I have my dot M file open
on my other screen obviously so that I
don't show everybody all my stuff
to
okay cool so harsh it's going to message
me the info so that I can I can try it
with with his database info that's
actually a good idea and then that old
that should help us narrow down the
issue
okay so let me see while I'm waiting on
on a Harsha - send me that info okay
cool I just got it
anyway I was going to say when we
probably later on whenever I finish up
with the coding and we do a question and
answer session I'm gonna let you know
how everything went with that react
native that just to make a lungs long
story short it passed the code review so
it's officially accepted I've completed
all the project for that nano degree
which is awesome
there's definitely a lot of work that I
still would like to do on it and I got
some really great feedback from my
reviewers so I maybe I might actually
turn that into some issues on the github
repo and then if anybody would like to
work on it with me then at least you'll
know some of the things that need the
need work alright so I got Harshit I got
your your info I'm going to paste that
now into my dot and file
okay I'm saving that and let me let me
restart this so you start this wait for
that to refresh
okay alright let's give this a shot now
okay so waiting
okay not sent let's see yep we got the
same same error
okay so since this same login info works
for Harshit on his machine then it's
probably it probably doesn't have
anything to do with my my login
credentials for the database it has
something to do I guess with my
development environment so well at least
we've we've ruled that out okay
okay hard sing hard code the string for
now okay I can hard code it I will I'll
do that on my other screen let's see
actually let me yeah
okay
oops
we
first that
okay still same there well almost the
same we had a bit more up here the last
time
Eric connecting the TV
interesting
I'm going to try that one more time I'm
just wondering why we got different
messages
okay
okay
hmm
all right
I'm gonna get off of this I don't want
that off day Esther refresh and show
harsh it's trying to use memory store
for now I'll different Express session
okay physically listen reacts yeah so
dragon hunter the the repo is bulletin
react
okay so harsh is saying try to use a
memory store for now [ __ ] from Express
session okay you're gonna have to help
me out with that because I've this is
the first time I've used [ __ ] and
Express so let's see
okay so I'm going to remove i'll go from
exposition
I make that big here sorry that was
probably too small for everybody
I had it smaller earlier there we go
okay okay so harsh the same I'm removing
so I'm not sure exactly where to remove
if if I remove this will that do the
trick are there other places where I
need to remove it from I'm gonna take
that out now and I figured I'd get some
sort of error okay so first we remove
that okay cool
okay so there's another place where we
have to do this that's okay dragon
hunter the branch someone right now is
it's actually harsh it's pull request
let me let me send you what PR is that
44 let me send you the get command I'm
going to take by the gate command if
anybody does want to check this out
but you're not familiar with how to do
this I'm just going to type it right
into the live chat it's get fetch origin
pull 44 and then age okay so get fetch
origin pool and then 44 I'll put this up
on the screen too if anybody wants to
see this later on so this is what I'm
doing git fetch origin pool so you're
gonna pull request number 44 and then
head and then at the end here you can
name this whatever you want but that's
what the branch is going to be called on
your local machine so this is what I
named it on my local machine but you can
name it whatever you want after you pull
this down you can switch to that branch
make sure you run npm install or yarn
because there's a lot of packages and
then you should be able to to work on on
this or at least follow follow along
with what we're doing
okay all right so let me go back to this
John Hanson says I remember seeing
something when using react with express
and connecting through MongoDB there can
be a shared connection issue between
Express and react which can default on
the same localhost 3000 okay so maybe
maybe we're dealing with with a known
issue here that's good to know because
there'll probably be some some
information about how how to fix it down
let [ __ ] DVD compass see where was let
me let me go back one so there was one
other thing that I had to comment out
well let's connect to the database from
a GUI first okay
we compass
be able to
could I use instead of compass the bongo
DB compass could I just use the command
line could I use the shell let me pull
pull one over to my other screen here
Harshit saying it will be very hard as
you don't have longer that well wedding
we should I mean all we really need to
test is whether or not I can actually
connect right so that that might be the
only reason I'm asking is because I
don't want to go through the to get the
free version of [ __ ] Compass [ __ ] TV
compass is like you gotta fill out all
your contact info and everything so I
was just going to try to avoid that and
I wanted to download the show anyway
oh here we go found another place where
it's gonna let me download it without
that alright I'll try that then I don't
know what that other page was but it
wanted a lot of contact info okay oh
yeah now it's making me do this again
I'm gonna show
so I'm trying to install the [ __ ] shell
but the the documentation page was just
saying how to use it and not how to
install it
cool I think I could just use brew to
install this let's see
okay so I'm gonna try to use homebrew
homebrew to install this
okay cool let's see
all right harsh dude I got your link I'm
going to open this on my other screen
okay so if you're just joining us you're
not sure what's going on when installing
some tools to help us test our database
connection so I have a few things going
right now so whatever tool ends up
getting downloaded faster is what we're
going to use
all right so the [ __ ] compass is has
three minutes left on the download
homebrew is now about 15% done
downloading [ __ ] so
so we'll see see what happens it's a
race so if you've never used homebrew
here's what's going on here so if you're
on a Mac you can use homebrew to install
packages so there are different reasons
why you might want to use home homebrew
but it can be it can be useful so I just
ran brew update which just updated
homebrew it's good good there if you
don't run homebrew often it's a good
idea to just do a brew update every time
you're going to install something new
and then I'm doing brew install MongoDB
so waiting on that looks like it's still
saying three minutes left on the [ __ ]
Compass something like the the home brew
install might might win the race here
okay let's see
[Music]
harsh harsh is saying check out all
changes you might have done some
breaking change is possible all I really
added in were console logs and I think I
actually got rid of all those so it
should be everything should be exactly
the same
I can always pull the pull the branch
down again
sirrah mad
okay
all right so now we reverted all right
so we do have Brian's asking about
homebrew so while we're waiting for this
to install we may as well talk about
number so homebrew helps you it's been a
while since I even read anything about
homebrew but from what I remember when I
was first researching this homebrew who
helps you use C you install these
packages but you do it in a way that
protects your system so I don't know if
sandboxing is the right word but I guess
it's it's somewhat similar to that also
it makes it easier really easy to update
things so like if you install yarn
through homebrew and you want to update
yarn you just run the update through
homebrew so there's no sometimes yarn
for whatever reason can be tricky at
least I've it's been tricky for me
probably because on some of my scenes I
use homebrew and some of machines I use
I installed it other ways so anyway I'm
gonna do my 5-minute break now and I'll
just continue talking about homebrew for
a minute here but it just kind of makes
it easy to be able I mean you can see a
lot of the packages here that are
available
this kind of simplifies installing
packages you know you don't have to go
like read the docs on how to manually
install any of these it just it's there
and it works so anyway I don't use it
for everything but it is convenient for
some things all right let me scroll up
and see what questions you all have and
try to answer as many as I can here in
this little break
Oh Goo's says I can't learn vanilla
JavaScript could you guys help me yeah I
would say if you're having trouble with
vanilla JavaScript I mean you can
certainly ask any questions here in the
live chat or you know ask me questions
on Twitter or something like that but I
think checking out free code camps
javascript exercises is a good way to
get your hang of get the hang of all the
syntax and run through some algorithms
and things there are other great
resources so code Academy has some nice
like in browser tutorials and there's
certainly a lot of YouTube videos
there's a great JavaScript series here
on free code camps channel that that Bo
recorded so you know check that out
there's also some good open source books
so the you don't know J S series is
available for free on github that's a
great series so there's a lot of
different things you could do to learn
JavaScript it kind of depends on your
preferred learning style I would say for
me things I like the videos and I like
reading and all that and the in browser
exercises but I don't feel like I really
get them the concepts and so I start to
use it in my own projects and and need
to modify things you know based on the
project requirements then I find myself
really getting the hang of these
different concepts so no matter what you
do to learn at first I would try to
spend some time every day just you know
a little bit of time every day actually
using those concepts if you can it'll be
much easier to keep those learn those
concepts and remember them if you do a
little bit every day as opposed to you
know maybe taking one day a week and
spending hours learning so that's that's
just kind of some basic advice if you're
having issues with a specific part of
JavaScript you know that
you know or let us know here in the live
chat and I mean we could help you with
that okay Blake asked about end rock at
the beginning and Rock is the the
service that I'm using to be able to let
you all see on your computer in your
browser the projects that I'm working on
locally and you can inspect them however
it's not really going to be of that much
use right now because of the way we have
the servers running so we will be using
it in the future but for right now it's
not it's not really gonna work and it
has nothing to do with n grog and rocks
working perfectly it's just what we have
one on right now with the project
Fernando says I'm from Argentina
I need a job
Fernando let's see if you if you're on
Twitter and you wanna if you send me a
tweet with I'm sorry if you tagged me in
a tweet that maybe has a link to your
github repository or your portfolio
website and just saying the tweet like
you know I'm looking for work this is
what I do I'd be happy to retweet you I
don't have that many followers I'm like
just under 600 right now but maybe some
of my followers may retweet as well and
some of my followers do have a lot more
followers on their account so that may
help I don't I don't know of any jobs
available right now and I'm not really
in a position to make hiring decisions
on my own where I'm working right now
but I'd be more than happy to just try
to get your name out there on Twitter a
little bit more so my link to my Twitter
account or at least my name on Twitter
is is in the description for this video
okay
all right so that time is up let's do
one more session hopefully we can get
things something figured out in this
session so let me scroll back down and
let me grab let's see I have all my
database info open on another screen so
let me grab this and paste this in here
okay all right so now that I have the
[ __ ] shell I'm going to let me get all
the all the info in here just to just
take me just a second I'm going to I'm
going to build the string that I need to
put in there on my other screen and then
I'll paste it into the terminal
okay so I'm not I'm not going to do this
on the screen I'm doing some another
screen because I have all my database
info in here but right now it's it's in
the process of connecting so let's see
what happens I don't know how long it
normally takes to connect
okay actually interesting okay so we I
did get by an error that gives me a
little bit more information here
hmm
okay so is definitely the problem I
think is with connecting to the database
let's see oh there's a lot of capital
letters in the live chat right now so
let's see what har should say okay so
harsh is saying that we should run a
local database all right so let's do
this
start dB
okay
okay all right so we've started MongoDB
let's see
changing to mondo vocalist bulletin
okay
all right let's whoops
okay so let me let me repeat what's
going on in the live chat here sorry I
think I've been pretty silent trying to
read this so for everybody they can't
see the live chat so what we're going to
try to do is locally run a database so
[ __ ] DB which we can do now since we
installed everything so we're going to
start this so we've run on my other
screen I guess I could pull this over
now because I don't have any special
there we go okay so let me the the zoom
one i therm is a little odd but anyway
alright so I was pasting the wrong stuff
in here but basically an R should let me
know so I did Bruce services start
MongoDB and it started a database and
then I mistakenly pasted this in here
before I saw your comment about where to
put that so let's
yeah okay so I've done the brewery
services start MongoDB and I'm gonna put
I'm going to change the dot n file
okay so I've changed the database in the
dot M file all right now let's restart
the server whoops
I have it here
oh no sorry start this up rates alright
as soon as this refreshes we'll test it
out
okay I'm seeing some hopeful things in
the console yes I hate okay so it says
the email has been sent
let me verify that I have my email upon
on the other screen and yes okay I have
the token and let me grab this token and
we'll paste it in over here so everyone
can see awesome
all right really cool so let me recap
just I guess I didn't need to zoom in
that much but let's recap would just
happen
so our it seems that our whole problem
for the last or at least not not our
problem it works your Harshit right away
but for me for some reason and possibly
this has to do with with my network here
although I did try it on another network
so maybe it's not I'm not sure what the
issue is but for whatever reason we
couldn't connect to the database that I
was trying to run through a service
called M lab so instead we installed
[ __ ] with homebrew and then we just
started up locally a database then I
replace the local database in our DB
hosts and our dot M file and that's the
dot n files where you put information
that you want to pull in as variables
but you want to keep that secret so you
don't put the dot end file in your
github repo and nobody ever sees that
okay get it it allows you to pull that
into your source code but it remains
hidden and you can still have things in
your repository on github and you don't
have to risk exposing API keys or
passwords or anything like that so
anyway so we changed our den file and
then we're able to connect to the
database so the authorization works as
stated and you know exactly how how it
was supposed to work so thanks harsh it
great job on that so awesome
well this is awesome so what I wanted
let's let's test some of this out right
great so you see we were able to log in
let's check out let's check out where
this is being stored at you have this on
local storage or in cookies
cool
all right so okay heart should say we
should test the form submission - that's
a good idea so the form submission was
working before let's test it again just
to make sure I'm just gonna put some
things in here and submit all right
submitted let's double check my email
yep I got it
actually let's try to do that with a
file as well so let's see let's send so
I'm gonna send something okay this is
reasonably thin this is something that a
PDF is something something we'll
probably get sent frequently so all
right and
okay cool when the attachment did come
through great
awesome okay okay so all that works all
right so we may as well merge this now
so let's go back to our our console and
what I'm gonna do first and I always do
this always do this when I have branches
that I'm merging is first we're going to
merge master into our other branch and
then if something really goes wrong at
least we haven't messed up our master
branch right so let's do get merge
master all right why are you up to date
I actually merged beforehand so I was
almost positive that was going to work
sometimes you may have merged conflicts
in this case there was there was nothing
harsh it does a good job of keeping
everything merged so anyway let's go
let's do a git checkout master up master
and now we'll get merge h off great okay
let me just double check we should be
all up to date with our packages but
never hurts to run it again great we are
up to date and now we'll do a git push
origin master all right that's going to
push our code up to github and then if
anybody happens to be looking at this
pull request it will change from open to
merge whenever we do this so we don't
even have to do anything in github right
from the command line it's it's going to
be taken care of all right great
okay now here's the thing though we
there's some things that will probably
change just so that we can all work on
this and test it out so for instance
right now you have to put in a
Franciscan University email address
now granted you could have it sent to
mail trap so like there are ways but I
think it's it's probably a good idea to
make some changes hopefully I can get
those changes done today probably not
doing the stream just to make it
possible I guess to skip the login since
we know it works basically so y'all can
get in and you're locally on your
machines and do you know check out other
things and do other type of work so
we'll see about that so for now just be
aware that it's going to make you log in
now if you try to download this okay so
let me bring over I guess I don't have
to bring over I just want to grab one
more pull request and that's the last
one that we currently have open which it
feels really good to get all these pull
requests taken care of I've been so
behind on getting things merged and
really it was it was this request that
we just sorted out now that was making
me fall behind the most I just kept
trying to troubleshoot and didn't
realize until we're there today that it
was most likely a database thing okay so
let's grab this poor request 47 and this
is where har should implemented the
masonry layout if you're not familiar
with that it with what that is hopefully
you'll see an example in just a minute
so let's do a git fetch origin pool 47
since it's pool requests 47 Ted and then
we'll call this H masonry all right
you don't have to name it H masonry you
can name it whatever you want but I kind
of like to put the first letter of the
name of the person who's doing the pool
request and then it just helps me keep
straight who who did what and it helps
me to be able to remember and give
credit to the
a person for doing this pool request so
now let's check out let's do a get check
out that new branch that we just created
masonry and now whoops I keep forgetting
I have the have a sent another screen
recognized for your component oops I got
to do a yarn it's a good idea to just
run yarn all the time when you're
pulling that down because if you don't
need it it won't hurt anything but if
you do need it it'll prevent you from
maybe trying to troubleshoot something
that you really shouldn't have to worry
about because it should have been all
taken care of
oops let's try to restart before we do
anything else
okay great this is another thing that I
found just from experience when you
update when you switch to a new branch
and you run yarn sometimes it's a good
idea just to restart your server I know
I've been very frustrated for a minute
when things don't work and then luckily
just a restart has been able to fix
everything so try to do those two things
run yarn or run NPM install and then
restart the server before you try to
troubleshoot anything it could save you
a lot of time I know I've wasted a lot
of time when I've forgotten to do that
okay so anyway here's what we're talking
about with masonry layout check that out
that's just that looks cool write that
all the cards just kind of flow so we
had we talked about CSS grid so maybe it
would be a good idea to explain the
differences between what's going on here
and CSS grid because certainly CSS grid
is much more simple to to implement but
what we had when we had the the grid was
first initially when we implemented the
grid we had these big gaps so we would
have you know one two three and then our
second row of three wouldn't start till
here so it looked okay for these cards
but then for this card there is this big
white space then Harshit was able to set
a uniform height for these and that got
rid of our gaps but then on cards like
this we would have a huge white space
within the card so what what masonry
does and behind the scenes what's going
on here is using some JavaScript to
position these so this is not CSS
positioning each one of these actually
has a position I mean I can you can
actually see it happening in the console
let's see
maybe try to get to the right spot here
and okay I guess the the first card is
not really that useful to look at
because all right so let me let me make
this a bit bigger see all can can see it
and then it'll be it'll be really
obvious what's going on behind the
scenes in just a second so let's bring
this over I'm looking right here at this
this positioning so it's absolute
position right now it's left four
hundred and some four and twenty six
pixels top zero so as we move you can
see the pixels changing so that's three
eighteen three fifty so and now we have
our top change so the absolute
positioning is constantly changing based
on the screen the screen size so that's
that's the difference there is the CSS
grid of course is CSS based positioning
and this is certainly it uses CSS right
which we're saying position:absolute
left top those are CSS attributes but
javascript is directly controlling those
so anyway that's how you deal with
masonry masonry can be a pain at times I
know in previous projects we had
implemented this with react before and
it took a while to get that that was
with project one it took it took a
little while to get it working and I've
tried to implement this with with some
jQuery stuff before it's definitely it
can be a pain at times especially if you
have images to get the positioning
correct you you need to be able to have
everything get repositioned whenever the
image is actually load there's a helper
library for that as well but there's a
lot of different things that could go
when you're using this but I think the
end result is is worth it and there's
cool things you could do with this like
like filtering to you know have things
just switch around you know on the fly
it looks nice there's different types of
transitions that you could use so this
there's different options so anyway
really nice great work on that hard [ __ ]
I really like that
and you can see you know our ListView is
still just regular ListView but when we
go back to grid view much nicer so great
that's great job and we should have the
same thing here when we go to our
categories as well right now we don't
really have enough posts to be able to
see you know the full grid in action
here but very nice okay
let me check my time all right so this
I'm almost done with this 25 minutes so
I'm just going to go into the live chat
now and answer some of your questions so
basically we've achieved what we met
what we wanted to achieve we've
successfully troubleshooted what was
wrong with our auth and with our log in
system and the problem ended up being
just for some reason I can't connect to
a remote database so we had to run it
locally so everything seems to be
working with that we're able to get this
grid layout in and I guess we could
merge that in right now as well since I
have a minute left it'll only take a
minute to merge so let's go ahead and
and merge that while we're here so first
let's do a git merge master all right we
have a conflict all right this is cool
I'm really glad we had a conflict ok
hard saying to try the logout ok cool
off shar the logout let me finish this
merge and then we'll try that ok
Harshit also wants to make sure that
that it is known that
to use materialized for masonry yeah I
did see that that comment in your pool
request so how should saying is a real
pain yeah I do I appreciate all the work
I mean I I know I've I've had a lot of
pain in dealing with this as well both
with react and with without react with
with some javis a query based single
page apps that I made before before I
started streaming so I definitely
appreciate all the work that went into
that
so let's um let's see oops
trying to find oh here we go alright
where's their merge conflict that it was
in that CSS file was it not okay alright
cool so here if you've never seen a
conflict emerge conflict it can look
different depending on what editor
you're using but basically you're gonna
have sections from each and then you're
gonna have a section where it gets kind
of telling you here's what we think it
should look like and so you get to
choose what you want so let's check out
what's going on here so our head is
going to be our current branch so our
current branch is that masonry branch
so whatever branch your own is the head
and then our other branches our master
branch so that's what we have currently
on a master branch so probably what we
want to do is keep whatever's in the
master branch so yeah we don't want all
this stuff so what we're gonna do then
is use master ok so you won't always
have that option it does depend on what
you're doing with your or what kind of
editor you're using my packages that you
have so you may have to manually
get rid of manually delete that but in
this case we can just click use me and
it handles it for us which is nice so
now we have this padding right important
I do believe we want to keep that but
let's see oh no we do we need that we
have it on body let me double check so
let's double check in I guess I can just
run this on the on my other screen let
me double check quickly what we have
here yes
oops I need index that's CSS okay we are
gonna keep that we are gonna keep this
right let me check the live chat quickly
Sebastian will know more than anyone
whether or not we need to keep this so
Sebastian if you're still with us in the
live chat let me know I mean this is not
really a big deal this is not hard to go
back in and change this let's see we'll
just we'll keep this in for now if we
notice that something weird is happening
with it we can always take it out but
anyway now I've saved that and we can
see if we go back in here we're gonna
commit so let me double check and make
sure ok was just with index it'll tell
you what files have have conflicts so
since it was just indexed on CSS we fix
those conflicts let's go in here and get
commit I'm gonna do a git commit I'm
gonna put the commit message right in
line here and say
okay it's running our tests great okay
awesome so the merge has worked
now let's well let's quickly just double
check and make sure everything's working
I don't really have any reason to think
that it wouldn't work but worth a shot
and then we can also test out our logout
as well all right looks good looks good
great what else did we have this bad all
right wonderful
all right let's test our logout okay
great we're able to log out and we'll
just test a login great that was nice
and quick we have our our token here and
awesome loves us right back in wonderful
okay now let's do get checkout master
and we'll do a git merge H mace H
masonry awesome now we have the masonry
branch here and we can do a git master
awesome so now everything should be
up-to-date we'll have all our pull
requests merge for the bulletins react
wonderful okay we do still have we have
one issue open and there's certainly
more that needs to be done so maybe I'll
try to add some more issues in here so
if anybody would like to work on them
you can work on them if anybody needs to
get those last few pull requests in
before for hack tober fast to get your
t-shirt maybe I'll try to put in some
some some of them are going to be more
difficult some of the issues
maybe you'll try to put in some easy
ones if anybody's kind of new to coding
but still wants to get the pull requests
in also I still don't have all my pull
requests in so if anybody has a project
that you need some help with and would
like me to open a pull request for your
project let me know send me a link to
your repository and let me know what
need what you need work on so now that
I've finished my class I may have a
little extra time to work on stuff like
that so I probably won't be able to like
do anything really significant but you
all helped me out so much it'd be cool
if I could help you out with something
as well all right so let me go through
the live chat now and that'll be the
last thing that we do let's see so if
you have any questions please put them
in the live chat now I'll do my best to
answer all the questions if you don't
have a question please consider sticking
around and helping to answer some of the
questions I'd love to have your
expertise to help give the best answers
we can to everybody that's that's asking
questions but if you can't stick around
you can always catch the Q&A session
later in the recording and please join
us again tomorrow should be around the
same time today was a little later than
normal but I like to stream around 2
p.m. Eastern Time we may will probably
end up working on some UI stuff tomorrow
I haven't decided for sure but maybe
we'll work on some of that we've had
some heavy back-end stuff lately so it
might be nice to switch it up do some
some front end you know CSS work so but
let me know if anybody
as anything specifically they'd really
like me to go over tomorrow let me know
in the live chat right now or send me a
message on Twitter and if if it's doable
within the scope of the project I'd be
more than happy to to steer the stream
in that direction okay let me find where
I left off
there we are
oh you know before I forget yesterday I
had I think it was harsh it asked about
freelancing and then I had someone on
Twitter as well asked about freelancing
so we'll see how much time the
question/answer takes maybe I'll talk
about it now but I've been thinking
maybe I should do a video a short video
and put it on my own YouTube channel
about my experience as a freelancer and
my advice to anybody that wants to be a
freelance web developer so if you think
you might be interested in that let me
know if nobody's really interested maybe
I won't take the time to do it but
otherwise if you think it might be
helpful for you I did freelance I was a
freelance web developer for three years
so and I still do freelancing on the
side so I'm certainly not the best there
is but I have a lot of you know
experience about five years of
experience so that at least I could give
you some advice over the areas where I
made mistakes in some of the areas where
I was successful
all right still I'm scrolling down
looking for questions a lot of this
section of live chat I was interacting a
lot during the the coding so things that
we've already talked about I'm just kind
of skipping it over okay actually Rohan
has a good comment here so previously we
were talking about homebrew and I was
trying to explain a little bit about
what it does but I like what Rohan says
here he says homebrew is a package
manager for apps for mac just like NPM
is for node packages so on Linux you
would have apps and YUM so if you think
of it like that I think that's
definitely on the right track that'll
make it easier if you've never done
anything with homebrew basically the
same thing does a very similar thing and
then what is
I forget the one that's for PHP but PHP
has something similar
okay rook asks if there's a Windows
counterpart for homebrew Rowan says it's
chocolaty okay that's awesome
I've actually didn't know that I haven't
really done anything on Windows for a
few years now but when I did a lot of
development on Windows I had no idea so
that's that's awesome so for everyone on
a Mac check out homebrew for as a
package manager but if you're on a
Windows machine check out chocolaty hug
harsh it reminded me that my timer was
not visible so sorry about that
I always forget I just I gotta get used
to putting it somewhere else I'm seeing
all the horseshit trying to get my
attention typing in in all caps so sorry
for all the stress that my inattention
cost you there I appreciate you being
persistent in trying to get my attention
though
okay earlier I was checking I think I
was checking on a different screen but I
was mentioning local storage and cookies
so I wanted to know where the where the
login information was being stored so if
you didn't if you didn't catch that I
was able to log in on this tab and then
this tab was still on the login screen
and I just refreshed I was automatically
logged in basically there's a cookie
stored now currently the the live
version of this that's a non react very
uses local storage to accomplish the
same thing basically to store user data
so that the login session can persist so
as long as you don't log out or clear
your cookies then it should persist so
actually not sure is if anyone has any
opinion on which is better to use
cookies or to use local storage let me
know I'd be interested to see if there's
if there's some good reason to use one
or the other I know I believe cookies
that have to be smaller so you have the
opportunity to store more in local
storage in this case we're not really
storing that much so it shouldn't be an
issue but if anyone's work with that or
has any opinion on that please let me
know
okay Harshit earlier i was talking about
how there might be an issue for for
someone else to log in and Harshit said
i i was setting up said you said that
you need the franciscan needy you
off-guard i simply implemented it yeah
yeah don't worry i'm not upset that you
implemented it i'm actually really glad
that you did that because that's exactly
what we need for when this goes live I
was just trying to think of an easy way
for other people to be able to
contribute to the project maybe without
having to set up a database and
everything because I still want this to
be as beginner-friendly as possible you
know there's some there's some little
things that people who are new could
could contribute to the project but they
may not be able to figure out I mean I
did a whole database thing I needed your
help to figure that out as well so I
just wanted to try to think of some way
to make it a bit easier so I'm thinking
maybe maybe I could put something into
where it checks whether it's in
development mode or production and if
it's in dev mode we just disabled the
log in and then if it's in production
then then it is enabled and then that
might be the better way so we'll
definitely still want to enable it and
test it before we go live with it but
when we're doing like UI work and things
maybe we can just just disable that I
know it's a tional II it's a pain like
on the live version if I want to use I
have authentication enabled all the time
even if I'm running it locally and it's
tough if I use like browser stack to
test the browsers and browsers that
don't have my local storage data so I
have to log in I have another email sent
and log in again on every different
machine I want to be on if I want to
test it on a phone or something like
that so I end up having to log in quite
a bit so it
be cool if we came up with a simple way
to disable the login for testing
purposes so anyway I just don't want you
to think that that was wrong to
implement that that was perfect that was
exactly what I wanted
okay rooks asking what all those
warnings actually mean the incorrect
peer dependency yeah let's check that
out but look at all these things all
right let me read down and see if
anybody else said anything
and see
okay I don't it looks like dragon hunter
said I can RM RF node modules and then
run yarn so would that get rid of this
I'll try that out okay so actually this
would be cool to run so if you end up
having weird problems with your node
modules I have done this in the past and
it has fixed some of my problems
it doesn't always but occasionally
basically this is like completely wiping
out all your node modules and
reinstalling everything and starting
from scratch let's do it it's not gonna
hurt the project it's just going to take
a couple minutes to get everything back
but what you're using so we're going to
use this RM RF oops RF do not use this
unless you're really sure because what
this is going to do RM is just remove
right but this is gonna remove
everything in a folder so all subfolders
all files everything so only use this if
you're really sure that you want
everything to be gone alright this stuff
does not go in the recycle bin this is
gone like forever gone so having said
that I know that I'm okay with my node
modules being gone I've done this you
know plenty of times so our node modules
and when we when I run this everything's
going to be gone and our node modules
folder is gonna be gone so let's go CD
right I can't I can't even get to that
that that doesn't exist okay our node
module so now we're gonna run yarn and
know we're still getting the same errors
okay so I guess I didn't fix it it's in
Korea dependency hmm I don't really know
what the issue is maybe if I updated all
of our packages it might work I'm a
hesitant to do that right now because
but sometimes when you upgrade packages
they break something if they're breaking
changes within the packages so I'd
rather not do that
at the end of the day the end of a
workday hum but let's just double-check
everything still works it should work so
let's refresh alright great still works
see all right let's go back to the live
chat
oh cool dragon hunter says actually that
grid is neat so a good job yeah
definitely good job harsh it really like
that
okay rook said I just got an email from
Codecademy that they teach grid now on
their CSS court course doing that later
get course first awesome yeah that
that's the CSS grid is really good for a
lot of things this is probably one of
the very few use cases that I would want
to go with something else just for this
in particular CSS is it's good it's
great it's always getting better but
there's still no easy way to do
something like this with CSS and be able
to have as much control over layout as
you could you know we're doing this with
JavaScript
okay John Hanson says grid so CSS grid
has grid Auto flow row column row dense
column dense which gives very tight fit
and you can set min max on the rows and
columns cool actually I would love to
see an example of some something like
this done with CSS grid if it's possible
to do something that that truly looks
like this if there's a pure CSS way to
do it I'm I'm definitely open to it
so I'm not aware at least the last time
I tried to implement something like this
which is normal CSS as far as I could
tell with with researching it there was
not a way to get this exact layout but
maybe maybe something's happened since
then with with CSS grid that allows it
Blake says my droid is isn't displaying
all my categories actually if you like
if you're having trouble with with some
of your files send me send me a link to
your repo let me know what's going on I
can take a look at it if you want me to
harsh it says so so you now like
password this NPM module I I don't have
an opinion about it yet because I've
only worked with it in terms of just
reading the documentation to be able to
understand what you did and try to
troubleshoot so I don't know that I've
used it enough to reasonably have an
opinion about it but it's definitely
working to do what we wanted to do in
terms of the password let's login so I
do like the results
Harshit says will I get a t-shirt this
as I have 20 PRS yeah I'm for sure you
have you have enough full requests just
on this project alone I mean I'm
assuming you did sign up for hack tober
fest so assuming you signed up you'll
definitely get to keep this shirt
okay so on Hanson saying so in react to
change state on an imported component on
click go up the Dom to retrieve a key
value then uses that key to array dot
fine using the key to locate it and pull
in the data I'm not sure I'm not really
sure how that works behind the scenes so
I'm not I don't know that I could
comment enough on the mechanics of what
is happening behind the scenes within
react okay cool it looks like a few of
you are interested in freelancing advice
oh cool thanks Harsha I mentioned
there's a package manager for PHP but I
couldn't remember it was its composer
all right that makes sense I am I was
thinking it started with like a calm I
was thinking compass but I knew it was
and I was just thinking that because we
used something called compass earlier at
least we're going to use it so awesome
it's called composer for PHP so for any
p8 I know we have some PHP people that
watch the stream so if you haven't
already used a check out composer as a
package manager for PHP oh cool and
Zuber mentions that rails have gem so
gems the package manager and for dotnet
the package manager is nugget awesome
thanks for that Zuber I don't know that
I've seen you that much in the live chat
commenting so I don't know if if you're
new here to the chat are you just
usually not able to comment in the live
chat that frequently but anyway welcome
and thanks for contributing okay in ass
where do you find customers for
freelance projects okay cool I'll answer
like I said I think I'm going to do a
video and in going more depth into this
but I'll definitely answer this about
freelancing right now so the questions
where do you find customers for
freelance projects so I'm just going to
speak from my experience and and maybe
try to give some advice some more
general advice but for me I'll tell you
I'll tell you what didn't work so I got
I think I got one customer through my
website through the contact form on my
website only one ever now I'm sure that
my website helped because people could
go there first and check me out or you
know whatever it probably did help but
the contact form on my
it was not really that useful I did sign
up for several different freelancing
sites so I think I did just call it
freelancer maybe it was called
freelancer so I did that one I did she
was the other one they still send me
messages all the time no I can't
remember what it was okay so I basically
did one where they send you potential
customers and you can bid on the project
so basically you have to buy like tokens
to be able to bid on it I only got one
customer from that and it was a really
small customer I don't think I made more
than $100 off of working with that
customer so that wasn't great the same
thing with the freelance website I
didn't really have a great experience it
seems like you have to to get projects
you just have to undercut everybody else
in terms of price so low that it's it's
basically like working for free it takes
a lot of work to get enough reputation
on those things
so I don't personally recommend that
unless you really have nowhere else to
go and you just want to get some work
for your portfolio then you know go
ahead and go to those freelance websites
what works for me the most was personal
connections and I know when I heard this
when I was starting out freelancing I
always I didn't want to hear that right
because I want to just be able to sit at
my computer and code and get customers
but that's not really how it how it
works freelancing is about selling
yourself just as much as it's about
coding so you have to be willing to talk
to people and let them know what you do
and you know be able to show them some
of your projects basically to talk about
how great you are and how great work you
have so if you're not comfortable with
that I would rethink freelancing or at
least think of a different
so here's what I did starting out that
really helped me I found someone who was
willing to do the work to find customers
and then they would give me the projects
to work on but they needed a go-between
between the customer and between me so I
didn't have to handle contracts I didn't
have to go to meetings with a customer
I rarely had to speak on the phone with
customers or email with them this person
did all the work now the downside of
that is that I made a lot less than I
could have if I had done everything but
it was nice because I got to focus all
my energy on my time on just doing the
work doing the coding so I was able to
learn a lot more than I otherwise would
have if I had to handle everything now
through that I was able to build up my
portfolio and focus on the coding and
then I was able little by little to get
some clients so at first maybe it was
through family connections I just let my
people in my family know you know aunts
uncles cousins you know hey I'm working
on this and then they would mention it
to people that they knew so I got some
work from that didn't make a ton of
money off of it but I was still trying
to build my portfolio I was able to
through social media let people know
what I was doing so I reached an even
bigger audience of people that I still
knew in real life and his friends with
but then they could bring me connections
so I had some of my best clients came
from a connection of someone who was a
former student of mine when I used to
teach high school their boyfriend needed
a website and then I did a website for
their boyfriend their boyfriend's one of
his best friends needed a website for
their company saw what I did and then
wanted me to work on their websites so I
ended up getting into the New York City
market through them even though I live
far away from from New York City then
through them the CEO of that company his
his mom and
dad runs several other companies in New
York and I was able to do websites for
them that ended up being one of my best
clients I made the most money off of it
was very very nice working relationship
steady income the biggest client I ever
had in terms of money I got because
through social media
someone who my wife went to college with
worked for a company and her father was
the CEO of the company found out through
my wife that I did websites because she
had just asked on social media hey does
anybody know anything about websites my
wife is able to say yeah got a client
from that that was when I did that
website and finally finished it and got
paid that increased my income by 25%
that year just from that one website so
basically my point is my best clients
came from personal connections sometimes
I didn't actually know the people but
people I knew knew those people so like
I said maybe you might be comfortable
this maybe you won't but what you really
should be doing if you want to make
freelancing work is talking about what
you do to the people around you you
don't have to be annoying about it you
don't have to only talk about that but
make sure that everybody on social media
knows who you are and what you can do
make sure that all your friends and
family know what you can do and that's
going to be your best clients if you
want to advertise otherwise so I did
paid ads on on Facebook on Twitter on
LinkedIn Google Ads
I did all those different ads I did not
get customers from those ads was it was
a good experience I learned how to use
all this products and be able to advise
clients on on how to use them search
engine optimization it helped to get my
website up to you know the
first page of Google near the top for my
local area but my best clients weren't
from the local area anyway so that
really wasn't it wasn't a big deal so
all those things are good because
clients will expect you to have them
they'll expect you to have good SEO
they'll expect you to have you know a
good presence on social media and stuff
and if you don't have that they might
start to doubt well like does this
person really know what they're doing
they can't even manage their own website
and brand so you have to do those things
but don't expect that those things are
going to bring you in a ton of clients
maybe if you were well-known enough at
some point it would help but at first
personal connections are where it's at
so I went on for a long time about that
sorry but it's really important the
other option that you have I mentioned I
found someone who is willing to be the
go-between between the clients and I
there are services that do that as well
if you can't find a personal connection
that would want to do that for you so
top towel is an organization that you
you take a series of tests so that they
know that you're a good developer and
then they set you up with clients they
handle all the contracts with clients
they're the ones that pay you directly
the clients don't pay you directly so it
cuts down on a lot of that stuff that is
not always easy to deal with right if
you I've had situations where clients
didn't pay me when they were supposed to
pay me and it can be a mess and it
really is stressful when you're counting
on income for your family and you know a
company is not paying you so that's a
tough situation that's another thing I
do recommend always always have a
contract I I worked without contracts
for a long time and I never had problems
and I thought it was fine until somebody
decided not to pay me and after that I
never did work without a contract so you
might be able to get lucky for a while I
got lucky with it for like two years but
then I had a client not pay me and it
just it took forever to get paid luckily
I did finally get paid but
months after I was supposed to receive a
payment so anyway I know I just threw a
lot at you hopefully I'll have some time
to put that in a more organized format
in a video at some point but let me know
if you have any other questions let me
know maybe it'll be good I can write all
the questions down and then try to make
sure I answer them in my video
Blake asks what should I use for
wireframing on Windows for free um hmm
I'm not sure of Windows what does the
thing Adobe came out is it called Adobe
XD it was something like that but I
don't know if it was free it might have
just been free when you they were
testing it so I'm not sure I don't have
anything that I use for Windows so I
don't know of anything but if anyone
else knows of anything good and free to
do wireframes on Windows please put that
in the lab chat now
okay John Hanson says I think the big
guys like Google are pushing for
developers to use local storage dragon
on it says go for local storage or local
forage module okay cool yeah maybe we'll
maybe we'll check into that it's
switching it over to local storage
Harshit says it would definitely be
harder to set that up so we'll check it
out
maybe we'll see how difficult it will be
if it'll be worth it to set it up I'm
for this project I'm not worried one way
or the other if we're gonna switch it
over I would want to do it because if
that's the the best practice to do then
I think it would be cool to do that on
the stream just to show this is how we
should do things but otherwise I think
cookies will be more than adequate for
this use case rohan says the it's quite
the irony because most of google
services rely heavily on cookies most
don't even touch local stores yeah
you're right actually
that's definitely true
rook says Google is weird like that they
don't even use angular from what I've
heard oh yeah I don't I don't know I
usually check with which sites are made
out of I haven't done that for a while
with Google Sites
everyone says using Google API is it's
quite common that you can see them say
to do the opposite of what they usually
say you would usually do really
frustrating but that's Google they use
angular across many things now
okay so dragon hunter says HTTP only
cookies are not vulnerable to XSS
attacks cross-site scripting attacks but
to CSRF attacks so the session could be
hijacked okay actually to be honest with
you for this project the data is not
really sensitive most of the data that
ends up in the bulletin is also publicly
available through other channels so I'm
not that worried about it to be honest
with you I never thought that this
bulletin should have to be password
protected that was a decision made
higher up and I fought against it but I
lost so I'm not super worried about the
security in terms of if somebody really
wants to find out you know the what's
going on in the bulletin like they're
gonna know the dates of when you can go
get training on PowerPoint and they're
gonna they're going to know what open
positions that we have at the University
which you can already find out on the
main website they're gonna see the
chapel's schedule for when they're there
are mass times which you can already see
on the main web site so there are very
few things it I would argue there's
pretty much nothing that should that
couldn't be public knowledge but anyway
I was told that an easy password
protected so that's what I'm going to do
and I'm gonna provide a reasonable level
of security but I'm not going to kind of
over engineer this so that we're
protected from all everything that could
possibly happen if at some point we end
up working with more sensitive data then
definitely yes I think we should be as
safe as we can but I think it
potentially could be a waste of a waste
of our time to really try to you know
make this solid and you know airtight
and no one can get in
Harshit says I remember some guy named a
folder it's the the little Tod icon and
and he did RM RF tilde and his whole
date it was wiped yeah yeah that you
could literally wipe out everything on
your hard drive with RM RF so like don't
use it unless you for sure know what's
going on dragon under says to choose
between CSRF and XSS definitely take
measures about XSS and forget about CSRF
soar local storage all the way
okay rook says I heard some guys on the
syntax podcast talking about how scary
our MRF is they suggest using something
called trash it's on brew okay cool
oh maybe I'll look into that right now I
I rarely use RM RF when I do use it
obviously like I I'm very careful about
it but if I find myself having to use it
more often might not be a bad idea to
switch to something a little safer
dragon hunter says is there a yarn lock
like npm yeah yes there is a yarn lock
file and then in a new version of NPM
there's the equivalent file ok harsh
it's saying basically since I'm using
react 16 many packages are not updated
that so that's that's probably why I'm
getting the warnings okay dragon owner
says our MRF node modules works with NPM
it seems to not with yarn yeah I mean I
guess if you really wanted to get rid of
it you should get rid of your yarn lock
file too so you could R get rid all the
node modules and your yarn lock and then
you could reinstall the from that way if
you really wanted it to be totally clean
slate all Roland says you could also use
the force flag to force reinstall of all
node packages all right good to know
thanks your honor
okay I think I think John Hanson is is
explaining more is his question earlier
about react like moving up to get I
don't remember exactly what it was but
he's saying vanilla Jas allows easily
moving up and down the Dom to create
comparison statement is true Falls to
render an object I'm not sure if it's
smart to do the same in react okay I'm
not sure I might need to see a use case
to give a decent answer to that so
anyway so John if you if you have a use
case then maybe I could I could give an
opinion on that
okay world's us how much would you
charge or get for an average project
okay I'm going to be I'm going to be
completely honest here about what I
charge and what I get so I'm not going
to name names of clients and they may
not want people to know what they what I
get paid but I'll try to be vague about
that but I'll tell you so when I started
out five years ago I started out working
getting work from someone else for $10
an hour so which is a little bit crazy
right I had two kids at the time and
I've didn't pay $10 an hour or working
less than full time doing this web work
but the deal was basically the guy he
knew me personally but he had no proof
of my skills he just knew that back in
high school I was smart and I was into
technology stuff and he knew he could
trust me so started me out and would say
like hey I'll pay you $10 an hour but
what I'll do is you know if you have a
project that I need you to work on and
you don't know how to do it I'll say you
know take two hours I'll pay you for two
hours to learn it and then do it right
so I was able to learn a lot so I
considered it like an internship only a
paid internship which it really was kind
of like that I learned a lot now what a
you did say as well is that every slide
on three months or something I'd be up
for a race so I ended up making more
than that quickly now along the way I
moved up certainly whenever I got my own
clients I would charge more I got to the
point where one of my last projects that
I worked on I ended up I did a react
site that pooled data in from the
WordPress API very similar to what we
did on
one of that we worked on it was actually
it was almost identical in terms of the
structure of the project as project one
which was the catechetical Institute
website and this project I did and I
believe I made eleven thousand seven
hundred dollars something like that
somewhere around so like around twelve
hundred dollars or twelve thousand
dollars for that website so there was a
whole range of stepping up what I would
charge people and then it did sometimes
depend on who I was doing the work for a
nonprofit occasionally I would do work
for free for a non-profit if I really
wanted to Baal volunteer or I would at
least I would give a discount sometimes
if you know someone that was family or
friend wanted something give him a
discount but in general when you're
freelancing it's always best to charge
more than you think it's really worth
because you have to consider more than
just the project at hand because there's
going to be over it so there's going to
be meetings with the client phone calls
you know Skype you know video
conferencing there's going to be work on
you getting a contract made and
discussing that getting that sign you're
gonna have to spend time sending bills
making sure your client actually sends
the bills so reminding them about that
potentially even having disputes over
billing there's going to be all this
extra stuff then you have to worry about
doing your taxes there's all this other
stuff that's involved that you need to
account for in the price so you're
always going to end up charging more as
a freelancer then you'd be willing to
accept as a salary if you are on
somebody's payroll and then don't forget
about insurance as well health insurance
you know sometimes your employer would
cover that but now you are your own
employer so always factoring more at
this point in my with my work I would
probably depends on the project
potentially if it was some project I was
really passionate about maybe I would I
would do it for less but I wouldn't even
consider doing work for anyone right now
for less than $100 an hour
if I was going hourly if we're talking a
flat rate I mean I don't know that it
would be worth my time to work on
anything for less than like $5,000 I
just wouldn't want to I just wouldn't
want to deal with the whole process of
building trust with a client and
contracts and billing and all that in
taxes unless I was making a decent chunk
of money like I said it depends on the
project if something I really wanted to
work on then I would probably be willing
to do less if something happened and I
really needed money I'd probably be
willing to do less but that's where I'm
at right now I have income coming in
that I'm able to pay my bills so I'm in
a different position if I was at a point
where I really needed to build up my
portfolio I'd probably be willing to
work for Less also it depends on where
you're at if I lived in San Francisco I
would I would never work for that little
I would work one even more money because
the cost of living is so much more I
happen to live in the part of the United
States where the cost of living is
pretty low the area I live is
economically depressed so I can I can
charge less people in big cities would
obviously want to charge more and then
depending on what country you're from I
it depends I don't know what you know
the economies could be entirely
different so anyway I could you know
keep that in mind especially if your
area like my area is economically
depressed try to build up your client
base outside that area for me I ended up
building a client base in New York City
I actually also had a client that she
was based in Hawaii
but she traveled quite a bit so I don't
know how often she actually lived in
Hawaii but those clients ended up being
the most profitable because they for
their market my prices seem like really
good prayer for them for me I'd make
from them more than anybody else was
willing to pay in my local area so it
was a great deal for both of us
you know they were getting a better deal
than they could get in their area and so
was I so those kind of seek out those
kind of deals and then you know you and
the client can both be really happy
about about what you're making hopefully
that helped the original question was
how much you charge or get for an
average product project so that was
probably way more than you wanted from
that question but I hope it it helped
you out at least some Blake as our vem
and Emax considered code editors slash
IDs
I think the minimax would fall under the
code editor category I don't think
they're considered IDs I don't use them
though I mean I've tried out vim but I
don't actively use them so I don't know
maybe for some I know there are some
people who watch a stream that do use
them so please correct me if I'm wrong
about that
okay harsh it's asking a question about
a specific piece of code so let me let
me get this on the screen
okay let me pull this over here all
right so let's check this code out so
Harsha's question is okay so she's a
verified label I have set up GPG keys
what do you think about this
actually I've never used these before so
let me see
okay cool so I I mean I think that's
cool that's fine to do what's the what's
the main benefit of the GPG key
well okay so earlier I mentioned Adobe
XD I didn't I didn't know what the
status of that was so it seems like the
beta version is is still free so if I
guess if you can get ahold of the beta
version then then you could use it John
Hanson says true Jesse talking about
what you do and know is a great selling
strategy I've had offers to build sites
I've had to turn down as I've got my job
beside some websites or beyond my skills
yeah actually that that reminds me is
well if even if you know other
developers and get to talk to them they
may send you projects like I know I've
had people ask me about doing websites
for them and I've just been too busy at
the time and so I've passed those
projects along to other developers that
I know and sometimes it works out really
well for those developers so if you get
to know other developers and let them
know that you're you're open annoying
work if they trust you and they've seen
what you can do and they know it's good
work then they probably will have no
problem sending people to you so that's
that's another good way to find work
heart should ask if I've installed
compass not yet it finished downloading
I didn't saw at the but Harsha says you
should see the database structure there
ok cool off to check it out
let's see if this bulletin was a real
project how much would you have charged
okay let me think about this
the bulletin so the bulletin site is
basically a blog site right it's a blog
site it's set up WordPress if two
different servers to set up probably not
going to run load balancing it's not
that important that it needs it
I set up the SSL now the complicated
thing I guess is the login but we may
even have more to login then we
currently have depending on on what
happens with the IT department here
let's see we have custom stuff done on
the WordPress end so there is going to
be custom post types who are already
running the graph QL plug-in so it's a
significant project I mean this this
would be this project I'm thinking right
now obviously is depending on the
organization and and fact there's you
know such as my time and things like
that but I'm thinking this website would
probably end up being you know more
closer to like a ten thousand dollar
site so our baby set that as a minimum
of 10,000 dollar site I mean that's just
kind of off the top of my head if I was
really gonna price this out I would I
would sit down and so like you know I do
with my Trello boards and I break things
down if I was really gonna give an
estimate I would break all the work down
like that estimate how long I take
everything factoring in the
obviously delays that normally happen
and the other stuff that you need to do
on a project so but a very loose
estimate would probably be I probably
wouldn't do it for less than than 10,000
so that would I mean and that also
includes like you know I'm doing this
for clients so there would be rigorous
testing there would be training involved
I would probably do training videos and
some in-person training for whoever is
going to be you know inputting the data
so it's not necessarily just the
development I would include that in the
cost as well but anyway that's what I
would charge now but they said it does
really make a difference there are times
when if I'm really busy and someone
wants me to do a website I I'll quote
them something more than I normally
would because my time is more scarce
therefore it's more valuable to me so to
make it worth my while to work on that
project which basically means for me is
I'm not gonna see my family while I'm
doing that work right so so for me it's
I guess there's two there's two sides to
the pricing is how much value can you
bring to the client which is important
because that's what they care about but
then there's also how much do you value
your own time which is also important
because that's what you care about so
you need to think about both things and
as long as what you value your time to
be corresponds roughly to what they
think the value you're gonna bring to
them through your website is going to be
then everybody's happy
right so you just gotta meet up you have
to find clients that kind of match up
with with that so I mean obviously when
you're thinking about how much you're
gonna charge like you do think about
your own experience and your skills as
well but because that will help you to
convince people that you're worth that
much anyway hopefully that helps I don't
know how much would you all charge where
you're from your area
and your skill set what do you think so
if anybody has any estimates I know it's
really hard to make estimates right on
the spot
but if anybody has estimates about what
it would be like in your area of the
world in terms of price let me know I'm
really interested to hear that
okay so the GPG code just actually
verifies that that's really the person
that says it is okay cool
that's what I figured I just kind of
want to know if there was some other
reason so yeah I like that that's cool
dragon owner said you should do some
podcasting you sound like an authority
figure I don't know about that I don't
actually have any authority
I guess my if I have authority it would
only be if if people value what I say
that would be the only authority that I
that I would have but I have experience
though so for whatever that's worth like
I can definitely give that
michail says hey Jesse watching project
2 day 2 now and saw that you went live
not really have a chance to watch online
but thanks make good work keep it up
Oh awesome thanks for stopping and in
saying that I really appreciate that and
hopefully you can join us live at some
point and let me know what you think or
any questions that you have we're
suggestions but anyway yeah thanks again
Blake says $10,000 as well
Harshit says you know $10,000 is a year
income in India I didn't know that but
that's that's cool to know world says it
used graph q oh and react yeah I mean
think about I think that's an important
point to remember a world sang use graph
QL and reacts like a client might not
necessarily know what graph QL and react
is or even care but as a developer like
we know the value in that that reacting
graph QL are really the technologies
that are I don't want to say emerging
because Reax been around for a while and
graph heels been around for a while but
in terms of like very widespread
adoption you know the vast majority of
the internet is still jQuery territory
right I mean as much as developers you
know kind of want to stay away from it
realistically it's used on a huge
portion of the internet right so some of
these newer technologies that aren't
really new to us because we're
developers but in the grand scheme of
things in terms of how much they're
really used on the internet they they
are pretty new they're pretty cutting
edge so the value of being able to use
those technologies I think warrants a
higher price tag now you may have
trouble convincing the average person
the average client of why this is
important for their site how will this
will help their site to be better right
so
while for a project like this maybe it
would be hard to find a client who's
willing to see the value in this and
want to pay that much so but if I were
to do a site that had everything that
we're doing using all the technology
that we're using I would want to charge
at least $10,000
so there's definitely that do I think I
could find a client locally that would
pay ten thousand no not in my local area
could I find one somewhere else
definitely I've no doubt about it I've I
personally have have known I know what
companies have paid for websites I've
worked on those websites as a
subcontractor I know so I I know enough
to know that there are a lot of
companies out there government
organizations and institutions that are
willing to pay an obscene amount of
money for products that aren't even
really that good
so if you're starting out $10,000 seems
like a lot especially if you're dealing
with like local small businesses but
when you get to another level of client
which should be the goal he really want
to make money when you get up there to
the larger organizations ten thousand
dollars is nothing to them you know
you're they're dealing with budgets of
millions of dollars so if they're gonna
they're gonna drop a hundred thousand
dollars on a website and budget that out
and saying okay we're gonna do a website
every three or four years we're gonna
get an update a hundred thousand for
this you know so it you know it breaks
down to you know maybe 20,000 a year
25,000 a year and they're gonna think
that's not really a big deal right that
doesn't even cover our electric bills
you know they're they're gonna think in
terms of I'm gonna spend twenty five
thousand dollars a year on a website I
buy one truck for my company and it's
probably gonna cost me $20,000 $25,000
right and they're mine like you got to
put it to them like that right the
website is the public face of a business
how much do people spend on building a
building for their business and making
it look nice millions right I'm
have homes that are in the millions of
dollars so a business to build their
actual physical business will think
nothing about spending millions on it
their website they're going to be able
to reach more people so put in terms
like that of how important it is ten
thousand dollars is nothing I can come
out with ten thousand dollars to some
companies and they would laugh at me and
say no because they're thinking the work
that this guy's doing must be terrible
if he thinks he can only get ten
thousand dollars off of this right so
when you when you're thinking about
things like that don't get discouraged
try to think in terms of what what are
the budgets for these companies you know
now if you're dealing with a really
small business that has three employees
and stuff yeah don't walk her in and say
I'm gonna build your website and it's
gonna cost ten thousand dollars they're
gonna say you got to be kidding me like
my rent every month is less than a
thousand dollars I'm not going to pay
you ten thousand dollars for a website
because potentially that could be around
here where I live
that's really it's reasonable as some
people have really low rents for their
buildings so because the area is so
depressed and other areas the United
States that's kind of ridiculous but
anyway just try to think like I mean I
guess I'm trying to like give you a
little pep talk at least to keep your
mind open to the reality of what
businesses spend and how they're
thinking and what they are already
paying for products so don't sell
yourself short just because something
might seem easy right to us building
this there have been some there's been
some trouble right there's been some
hard things right that grid layout that
masonry layout was a pain for Harshit to
put in and the the author the whole
authorization login system was really
impressive and that took some time but
really for us this seems like oh no big
deal we do this every day but there's
not a whole lot of people in the world
that can
this kind of thing and and do it
professionally and be trustworthy and
have it work and be able to handle a lot
of people that there's value in that
especially yeah big businesses see value
in that so don't sell yourself short
anyway I keep going off on these big
tangents I need to just make this
freelancing video and and then direct
you all to that or my live streams are
gonna end up being three hours long
every day okay okay so for this same
project rollin is saying in India if he
were to try to sell the same project he
would charge about three thousand five
hundred US dollars equivalent now in
India
Rowland says there really isn't much
demand for webpages or services here in
India small businesses will go for the
cheapest bidder and large companies have
their own team or will contract with the
whole team John Hanson says great advice
awesome thanks for that yeah I mean
hopefully the worst the client can say
if you come out with a really outrageous
offer that's our offer that seems
outrageous to them you know a quote for
a price the worst they can do is say no
but you know so what they say no maybe
you don't really want to work for a
company that doesn't value what you do
enough to pay you would what the work is
really worth so so you just don't be
afraid it's a bad path to go down to
constantly be apprehensive about what a
client's gonna think is reasonable and
try to always undercut yourself because
you go down that path and where does it
stop you end up doing quality work for
less money than you should and then you
get the type of client who doesn't value
your work so even though you know you're
giving them a great deal they don't
understand that and that's not really
the type of client you want to be
involved with I've been there I've been
involved with that type of client you're
giving them a great deal and and they're
trying and then at the end of the day
what they do is they try to you know if
if you're saving them a thousand dollars
off of what they would pay they're still
gonna try to squeeze out you know an
extra hundred dollars off you in the end
and said well I'm not paying for this
because something's off with it right
that's what that's what ends up
happening so just go for good quality
clients that are willing to pay with
something's worth and you'll be much
happier if you have to take the the
cheaper stuff to build your portfolio up
there's nothing wrong with that if you
have to take some of that stuff to pay
the bills and take care of your family
there's nothing wrong with that I've
been there and I've done that but when
you get to a point where you're
comfortable enough with your finances
that you can afford to take some risks
go for the bigger clients and then
once you get there and get those clients
in your portfolio it'll be a lot easier
uh okay let's see Blake says thanks did
you see the link for the repo I did not
see the link for the repo did you paste
them in live chat I missed it
if you could paste it again that'd be
great I could try to go back through and
look for it but it'll be more of a sure
thing if you could paste it again Oh
Harshit says yes you tried doing UI for
emails tomorrow if you really want me to
do you eyes for email I will do that but
for those of you that have worked on UI
for emails you understand where I'm
coming from I'm sure if you haven't
you'll see it's not it's not the easiest
thing but I'll do it if that's what if
this what you all want to see okay cool
thanks Blake I got the URL now all right
haha world says companies aren't
apprehensive in selling you a smartphone
for a thousand dollars yeah you're
absolutely right I mean think about
think about what companies expect you
all to pay for their services and then
you know maybe it'll make it easier for
you to to charge them more
all right so a Blake Blake let me know
what in particular you want me to check
out on this on this repo and I'll try to
check it out
and you can you don't have to tell me
now if you want to make an issue on the
repo then we could like we could talk
about it you know in the comments of
that issue if you want however you want
to do it
okay well I'm to the end of the live
chat now I think we had a great chat we
probably spent more time talking than we
did with coding but today I feel like is
the first time in a while that we
accomplished everything that we wanted
to accomplish actually a little bit more
I didn't even expect to do the masonry
layout and get that all merged in so we
actually accomplished even more I know I
ended up talking a lot so sorry if it
was too much but I hope I helped some of
you out and sharing my experiences with
with freelancing but this dream has been
really long and I'm actually like really
hot and sweating right now because it's
all in my office I didn't want to turn
the fan on and mess up the audio so I've
got to get a drink and get out of this
office my wife just called me too so I'm
gonna see what she needs and I'll be
back tomorrow thank you so much for all
your help
Harshit especially thank you in
Sebastian for your pool requests you all
have been great and I mean Harshit I
knew you're talking about freelancing
stuff and you're still a student and
you're young so that makes it hard but
you have skills
you definitely have skills so you just
need the right connections and I think
you'll be fine and in terms of doing
work right now though when you're young
this is a great opportunity to study and
work on those side projects that you
really really want to if you need the
money I totally understand if you got to
take some projects but otherwise I
wouldn't worry about freelancing so much
right now I would worry I would try to
take advantage of this time in your life
to work on things that you really want
to work on because once you start
working for clients you don't have the
same amount of freedom like you could
now so but anyway I think you have a lot
of talent and I think so many of you in
the live chat and the watch the shows
have so much talent I'm always impressed
with with which you all show me so
anyway thank you and I will be back
tomorrow
so until then
have a great day